[Music]
china is the source of covid lies
constantly about kobit and yet may win
the global political battle over cobid
because it exports vaccines while the
u.s doesn't the u.s should utilize our
huge advantage in vaccine technology to
help the world
american vaccines are the world's best
reported effectiveness is highest
against known variants
backed by far more comprehensive data
than nearly all others
by the end of february the us provided
20 million more doses to our population
than china provided to its much larger
population
china is in no rush to distribute its
inferior vaccines at home
it's exporting them though the us
rightly won't export until most
americans are vaccinated
that could happen by the end of july
then a superior american vaccine should
be offered to key countries such as
indonesia and its 270 million people
many lives can be saved the u.s supports
international production and
distribution of our vaccines
the way we've done so at home and the
world would see the american system
creating and sharing the solution to a
terrible problem
a problem caused in large part by the
chinese system
after most americans are vaccinated
should the us spend money to make our
vaccines available around the world
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and make sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei